sans excuser députés ont voté à
l'unanimité ce projet de loi dont le
volet phare est spécifiquement consacré
au harcèlement de rue cette nouvelle
infraction sanctionnera en flagrant
délit des comportements et des propos
sexistes
désormais pour les gestes déplacés
commentaires sur le physique
sifflements regards insistants ou le
fait de suivre une personne
la loi française prévoit une amende
immédiate de 90 euros qui pourra monter
jusqu'à plusieurs milliers d'euros en
cas de récidive ou circonstance
aggravante
merci pour tout le travail que nolan
chape amélie très l'égalité hommes
femmes a évoqué l'urgente nécessité
d'agir aujourd'hui nous refusons cette
fatalité et nous posons avec cette loi
un interdit social claire face à ce
harcèlement quotidien que vision encore
trop de ces femmes et qui entrave leur
liberté de mener leur vie comme bon leur
semble et cette initiative suscite
plutôt des réactions positives une
excellente chose parce que c'est vrai
qu'à pareille en a de plus en plus on va
dans le métro même dans leurs aires
c'est assez courant bon surtout pour les
dames qui sont pleines et donc c'est
vraiment une bonne chose qu enfin le
parlement prenne en compte ce genre de
harcèlement
je doute que ça change du jour au
lendemain du moins je l'espère si les
personnes sont vraiment sanctionnés et
que les choses sont immédiates et qu'il
y a des moyens mis en place pour alors
petit à petit oui ça changera sûrement
il faut dire que l'opinion est
sensibilisée au problème après un récent
cas de harcèlement et violence qui a
beaucoup choqué fait rare la scène a été
filmée
on y voit un homme frappé violemment une
jeune femme au visage en plein paris car
celle ci a osé répliqué à ces propos
obscènes
courageuse elle a décidé de porter
plainte et de mettre en ligne la vidéo
surveillance pour alerter l'opinion
l'ironie c'est que la policière qui a
pris ma plainte elle même m'a dit
qu'elle était victime comme ça de l'art
seulement toutes les femmes il y en a
pas une qui n'a pas eu une histoire de
harcèlement en fait c'est là qu'on voit
la gravité des choses
d'autres pays ont déjà pris des mesures
contre les harcèlements de rue comme la
belgique ou le portugal la finlande a
choisi comme la france de punir les
harceleurs sur le fait les premières
amendes tomberont cet automne cette loi
sera sans doute difficile à appliquer
préviennent les policiers mais pour la
ministre qui a porté le texte marlène
schiappa l'important est de changer les
mentalités pour que le harcèlement de
rue ne soit plus tolérés si gabriel
dejazet radio-canada paris